foreign
[Music]
Welcome to our Friday episode boys react
we got a guest house filling in Nick how
you doing
Ben thanks for having me I'm doing great
it's the Nick Huber show today yeah yeah
exactly thanks for having me on
um all right let's uh let's go through
some news items uh do some rapid
reactions first of all the big news
everyone is talking about on Twitter is
chat gpt4 uh it's the newest version of
the AI uh it's programming simple video
games doing pong on its own stuff like
that uh convincing task rabbit workers
to complete captcha for it so fellas
what are your thoughts on the new chat
GPT have you used it Nick I haven't used
it
I think these people need to go outside
and touch some grass
you're not a fan no I think it's all a
joke
dude you are so gonna get left behind I
I'm I'm I don't use it but I know that
it's gonna change everything uh darmesh
from HubSpot created this thing called
um uh uh chat spot and basically you can
do a bunch of stuff but you can like
talk to HubSpot and tell it what to do
so you could talk to it like a human and
like you know hubspot's really complex
like it does a little bit of everything
and you can just use normal words and be
like make my website look like this or
uh email these types of people who are
on my list and I think that's like a
really good example there's this uh you
know what like the best iteration of AI
right now is if you watch Monday Night
Football you know how they put the one
line or the the you know what do they
call it I don't [__] foul football
first first down you know the yellow
strip on the thing that's AI or you know
how when you back up in your car and you
see like a 360 view of like everything
around you that's AI so my theory is if
you have to say this is AI and the
product is good because of that that's a
horrible way to go about it but if it
just freaking works all the time that's
a great way that you know the product is
gonna be good so anytime something says
AI or web3 and they have and that's how
they explain it I go I'm out but I'm
convinced they're gonna figure out
another way how to do this did you laugh
because I didn't know anything about NFL
no I think uh I think that was a great
explanation and I don't want to like
I'll preface this by saying I think
these people are brilliant and this will
be a tool that makes people more
productive absolutely now let me tell
you that 99 of humans and Americans and
everybody else gives two shits about AI
they're worried about enough money
coming in their bank account on Friday
to pay rent on Monday and if their house
is maintained and if they have food to
put in their kids bellies
um it's absurd like literally we have a
whole physical world there's grass that
needs mode it grows can you believe we
plant we plant this green [__] around
our houses that every week we have to go
outside and cut it by hand with a
lawnmower we got to go outside and do
that we got to wash our houses we got to
clean our floors we gotta install carpet
we got to repair windows we have a
physical world that's crumbling around
the United States nobody cares about AI
dude you need to get out of Georgia man
you're gonna you need to get out of
Georgia hang out with the real people in
San Francisco and New York so you
actually know how real people live Sam
you didn't have me here to agree with
you
uh all right but let's do mint okay
let's do a minute um we talked about a
little bit last episode but T-Mobile is
set to acquire Ryan Reynolds mint mobile
he owns 20 to 25
uh for
1.35 billion dollars uh guys thoughts on
this what's 25 of 1.3
the 30 300 million dollars yeah
holy crap more so and then he how much
did he sell what's it what's his gin
called or whiskey or whatever the hell
it was Avi Avion or something
he sold that for hundreds of millions of
dollars recently so this guy is killing
it that's awesome I 25 seems like a lot
of equity to give to him right I think
it I think it's crazy I mean I think
this is exciting to me and it should be
exciting to you Sam too because it's an
example of somebody with clout somebody
with a personal brand somebody who
everybody likes and loves which is in
the definition of Sam par they've been
able to capitalize that they've been
able to capitalize that to an insane
degree and I'm excited about what it
means for people with distribution
meaning if you have ears and you have
eyes and people care what you have to
say you can get involved in products and
you can grow massive companies Sam's
doing it I'm excited about doing it
um it's just the beginning how much more
famous is Ryan Reynolds in both of us a
hundred times is he a hundred times more
famous of course you think more more
than 100 times so what's what's 100
divided what's his exit divided by 100
and how much money is that
is that two is that two million
still if it's 20 that would be a lot
cooler but uh uh yeah I I think it's
cool I I like him he's very likable he's
significantly more likable than both you
and I combined I think I'm like more
likable that I'm a lot more likable than
you and he's a lot a lot a lot more
likable than me so I'm a lot more better
looking than you and he's a lot more
better looking than me
uh I think it's awesome I like Ryan
Reynolds so Kudos I want to know I've
been asking him to come on this pod for
a while I want to know does he actually
do anything you know like what he
actually does uh what's his day like I'm
very curious yeah what do you think his
day is like Sam I bet he's going I bet
he's waking up he's taking a 20-minute
meeting where somebody tells him yes the
whole time that all of his ideas are
amazing then they're going back and
running the company without him or is he
super involved is he getting involved
with management is he doing marketing
decisions oh I want to know how
operationally and embedded he is in this
company
what would you what would your guess be
Sam how many direct reports does he have
at the company
well zero I think he has zero I think he
probably has the chief of staff who
manages his whole life but zero I think
that I I don't know much about MIT
mobile if I had to guess I would say
it's mostly a sales company meaning they
probably just like layered on top of an
existing Telecom and then just had a
slightly different pricing structure and
then targeted their marketing towards a
certain type of person I think MIT
mobile is more like a uh like a I think
it's like a working class thing because
it's like a it's all about price so I
think it's like a really really low
price here's a question for you Sam do
you think a a serious operator or
entrepreneur or executive is in the
background overseeing all of Ryan's
Holdings or do you think that he is that
entrepreneur I think he's the guy man I
think he might be the guy I think he
might be a leader in these companies
so but here's mitt's thing I said
they're a sales and marketing
organization because their commercials
are wonderful and I think they're
wonderful because he says a lot of funny
stuff on the commercials and he just
does a really good job of uh branding
the company and I think they knocked it
out the park with that where they did a
really good job of being irreverent but
still professional and I think that is
what he does where he's like this
crosses the line here's the line that we
can we can tow and how far we can push
it and I think that's what he does which
I think is easily worth the 25 because
if I had to guess it's mostly a sales
and marketing company and he crushed it
so this is a person that found an
influencer with distribution they knew
they could build a company
that got him involved and they put
together the ultimate system I love that
business model I think it's awesome good
job to Ryan Reynolds let's do two more
let's do the original iPhone yeah let's
do we'll do this one quick uh so a woman
in 2007 buys an original iphone right
when it comes out she keeps it in the
Box doesn't touch it for 15 years and is
now selling it just sold it at an
auction for 63
000 what are your thoughts on that
awesome you want to know what I collect
this is weird
um but so my wife Sarah worked at
Facebook now she works at Airbnb so like
these like pretty like culturally
important companies where we look back
in 100 years and maybe it'll be like a
Ford or something or GE and so whenever
she gets gifts like from Airbnb they
brand it Airbnb I tell her don't open
any of them and I collect all of them so
I have like an Oculus that's unopened I
have Airbnb swag that's still in the
gift box I have Facebook a Facebook book
bag that's unused I collect all of this
stuff I love it I love collecting this
like iconic company stuff and so what I
want to get is a Silicon Valley Bank
shirt I really or a Silicon Valley Bank
hoodie or uh what's the Sam bakeman free
uh uh yeah FDX or fbx I want to get one
of those I Really Wanna I would kill for
a thranos
um or theranos blood blood thing like I
collect all that stuff when Twitter was
auctioning off a lot of their office
equipment I tried to buy a bunch of it
and I and it all it went all above what
I was going to pay but I collect all
that stuff now what I really want to get
I want to get a monitor an old Apple a
Macintosh monitor that has the apple
with the uh like with the rainbow colors
or I want to get the desktop Mac that
remember the ones that were pastel
colors like the blues and the pinks and
all that stuff I want one of those and I
just want to hang it on my uh shelf I
love that stuff this is awesome I'm
happy someone did this I fully support
collecting and storing totally worthless
[__] I think that everybody should buy a
ton of totally worth the stuff and put
it in storage units right now put it all
right in a storage unit and you can use
a company called bolt storage to do that
just leave it forever I think you should
just keep it for all times but no in
reality we bought a I got a funny story
we bought a property at auction it had
187 units it was in Erie Pennsylvania we
went and every unit had been abandoned
we had to go through and saw off like
the locks and open them up and there was
dust and there was craziness oh that's
some really cool things we found a ton
of really cool things one one unit had
like 60 bags of white powder we
immediately called the police we never
found out if it was drugs or not another
one had a squirrel holding a baseball
bat another one had an old Indian
Motorcycle oh what type do you know what
year I got a picture I'll show you the
picture when we get off this call
what did you sell it for
it auctioned I have no idea like we
can't we technically couldn't touch
anything in the units we had to take
pictures of them and have an online
auction and the people bid on them and
then they came and cleared out the units
do you know uh how old it looked did it
look like it was from the 30s
no no no it was it was probably like not
that old of a pretty dumpy one if I had
to guess oh dude some of those old idiot
motorcycles you can get 50 60 70 000
well that's awesome
um that's badass that's a lot of fun
actually to go and like see all that
crap but anyway on board with this lady
who bought it Ben did we know just some
some nerd some fan
um
I don't think we know I don't think we
know dude I remember when that came out
in 2007 I was a sophomore in high school
and someone was watching YouTube on
their phone and we were all like
standing around it and that was like it
was like hearing the Beatles for the
first time you know it was like it's
pretty amazing it was it was
mind-blowing seeing that so that's
awesome um all right let's do one more
all right last one
the reason that Sean is not with us here
today A Massive wind and rainstorm has
left more than 200 000 people in the San
Francisco Bay Area without power
fellas any thoughts and prayers for a
comrades For the Working Class People of
the Bay Area any any thoughts for those
people did that really happen I didn't
know why he didn't have power uh I mean
that stinks I think every responsible
this is going to sound very radical I
think every responsible man should have
Provisions to keep their family alive
for two weeks with no power and no
internet
what do you have no I'm not I'm not a
doomsday person who thinks they need to
survive a zombie apocalypse and build a
bunker to live for six months but I
think if you have a generator some fuel
some ready to eat packages and a way to
get clean water and a like Hungry Man TV
dinners yep of course a way to defend
your house if people come for that stuff
you're going to be better off and every
man should have that set up in my
opinion it's like a very small
investment and it goes a very long way
if [__] ever did hit the fan imagine
being alone Sam could you keep your
family alive for two weeks if everything
if your phone internet cut off power cut
off
everything gone what would you do the
grocery store
no dude I I am a mini I'm not quite a
prepper but no I'm prepared we have uh
yeah I have that uh because when the
Austin snowstorms happened and then
covet happened and then when a lot of
the riots were happening I I definitely
got fearful that's one of the reasons
why I bought my Ranch is we have stuff
out there
where we can bug out to so I'm on board
with that
um I don't think I'm ever gonna have to
use it but uh I agree it's a very small
price to pay for insurance what do you
do with the gas do you replace it every
six months no you put it in uh there's
these things the military uses and you
put stable in there and you can keep the
gas safe for five to ten years you can
order them right on Amazon for 90 bucks
you fill it up with five gallons of gas
that's all you need then you got a good
generator you can keep your food cold
and you know your kids kids warm if it
gets really cold what type of food you
have you order some uh I think Peak Peak
is the brand p-a-k
um it's like a little freeze-dried food
that'll last 20 years and you keep it in
a little package
in uh in in January when whenever covet
happened
um I had this Chinese intern working for
me he had family in China and he was a
like a foreign exchange student and he
was awesome and he was you know on
what's the app that they use uh WeChat
and he was like Sam this coveted thing
this is like a huge deal this is it's
going to come to America and I was like
hung this is America dude we don't like
wear masks we don't have these types of
things that Asia has like this this
doesn't happen here well you're crazy
the next month he goes dude it's coming
it's going to be here and then March
happens and we see in the news the first
case in Seattle and then eventually Bay
Area and I was like hung you're right
I'm wrong I am so sorry and I went
immediately to the grocery store and
bought as much crap as we could and like
I had like storage we I remember like I
I was like you're right now I understand
why why people are afraid of this stuff
and why like the peppers exist you're
totally right and ever since then my
opinion has has changed on uh a lot of
this stuff so uh maybe it's like a man
thing when you get a little bit older
and start having a family I'm not sure
what it is but Cove had definitely
opened my eyes to like you know it's
nice to prepare for this the worst case
scenario I know a lot of guys who go way
overboard and they uh like they have two
years worth of stuff I'm not yeah it's a
slippery slope that's the thing about
prepping is it's a very slippery slope
and you got to have a discipline hey I
don't need more than two weeks worth of
crap to keep my family alive but you
want to know the other issue it's really
really fun all the gadgets like the
different flashlights the different
generators like I just love gadgets so I
just buy this stuff all the time I just
bought Sarah this like thing that will
break your glass if it go if your car
goes underwater and you're like when am
I gonna use this I'm like probably never
but like it's sick it was only 12 bucks
on Amazon like I love all that crap I'm
into it the best way to Save a Life the
best way to save life is put a
tourniquet in your glove box everybody
should have a tourniquet because a
motorcycle yep a motorcyclist or a
cyclist gets hit on the road 95 of time
you could save their life by being able
to stop the bleeding but a lot of people
can't so put a tourniquet in your car
dude you saw the other day how I held
that t-shirt up to that guy's head uh
like I saw a guy I saw a guy fall and I
gave him my shirt and we stopped
bleeding yesterday at the Meetup a guy
was like uh worked in the military he
goes hey I got this for you and he gave
me a tourniquet and so he goes next time
this happens here's how you use it and I
was like all right so I have a
tourniquet in my car now so I'm on board
uh that's the news is that it Ben that's
it thanks guys thanks for having me boys
[Music]